il était au départ une dizaine de jeunes
immigrés ce qu'on appelle les immigrés
de la deuxième génération c'est à dire
ceux qui sont nés en france de parents
immigrés c'était au lendemain des
agressions commises l'été dernier contre
plusieurs des leurs l'idée était simple
parcourir la france pour proclamer le
droit à l'égalité et le refus du racisme
ils sont partis le 15 octobre de
marseille il était alors un peu plus
nombreux une quarantaine destination
finale paris aujourd'hui ces marcheurs
sont arrivés à amiens ils ont vu des
français tout au long de leur voyage ils
ont parlé avec eux ils les ont aussi
écouté
isabelle bechler a voulu connaître leurs
réactions ils sont une quarantaine
moyenne d'âge 24 ans il y à du gant 10
et du luther king dans leurs démarches
mais surtout une énorme impatience d'en
finir avec le racing nous avons
entrepris donc ça est lutte en espérant
que a mené la majorité des français à se
poser la question suivante qui sont dans
la sphère les gens qui créent
l'insécurité qui sont les électeurs qui
sont les gens du mans est ce que ce sont
nous jeunes issus de l'immigration car
ont décidé de lutter de manière non
violente et de faire le premier pas donc
et de dialoguer les gens ou bien est ce
que ce sont les genres à six qui raciale
toute la question est là depuis deux ans
une quarantaine de jeunes maghrébins ont
été tués ou blessés dans les banlieues
des grandes villes
d'ailleurs l'idée de cette marche est né
dans la cité des minguettes à lyon pour
réveiller les français endormi sur les
lauriers socialiste faut qu'il se
remobilise contre le racisme plus la
marge progresse plus les soutiens
affluent à strasbourg on n'avait pas vu
de 1000 personnes dans la rue depuis
belle lurette agitation avec un peu
parce que je ne veux pas vrai avec des
vip et
mais j'en suis à la tête et sa faible
insistera comme ac/dc vie qu'est ce
qu'il faut pas quand même un peu arrêter
leur astuce si tu passes ton commence à
tuer égalité dignité compréhension
mutuelle ce sont les thèmes de campagne
des marcheurs qu'il soit enfant
d'immigrés ou français comme marie laure
bon j'ai été à l'école avec des gens
d'origine étrangère je serai amené à
travailler aussi avec avec ces gens là
donc je dois pas faire de discrimination
c c'est mes amis au plan professionnel
au plan privé bon c'est pour ça qu'il
est important qu'il nous confiance
qu'ils aient une vie passée puis qui est
une compréhension entre les uns et les
autres
surprise chaleureuse dans le week end
alsacien des marcheurs georgina dufoix
est venu marcher et parler quelques
heures avec eux le ministre et les
marcheurs se retrouveront le 3 décembre
à l'arrivée à paris
effectivement cette marche arrivera le 3
décembre et un grand rassemblement aura
lieu place de la concorde à cette
occasion